Instead of just calculating an IBS score percentage,
IBD focuses on using this IBS, in a
particular order on your chromosomes. It helps you
determine which piece, which piece of the chromosome came
from, from who in your family., For example,
let's think about the chromosome pieces you inherited from
your grandparents. Here we have your grandmother's chromosomes
and your grandfather's chromosomes. Now, your mother has her
own set of chromosomes. She got half from
her mother and half from her father; half from
your grandmother, half from your grandfather. Now when
your mother's germ cells went through miosis to make
eggs, Recombination allowed our chromosomes to mix and
match the grandparental chromosomes, her parental chromosomes. So that
when you inherited a set of chromosomes from your
mother, you got this interesting mix of your grandparents.
Now you could do the same thing for your father. And we could add up how
much each grandparent contributed to each chromosome. And
you'll see that it's roughly 25%, right? Here you
have half of your chromosomes came from mum.
And of those half, you'll notice that the
blue segments represent about half of that. So
total, 25% came from each grandparent. If you and
a grandparent actually participate in a service
like 23andMe. You can see exactly which segments
of the chromosomes you share with the grandparent
and the fact that you're roughly 25% related
to each other. Although the individual sizes and
chunks of the segments you may share with
the grandparent can vary, roughly speaking would be
about 25% related. Through IBD to a grandparent.